it has been a busy few days for
President Trump on Twitter he's once
again slamming the Special Counsel
investigation into alleged Russian
collusion and his presidential campaign
and urging scrutiny of the Hillary
Clinton campaign and effort the
president is also linking the probe to
the coming midterms chief intelligence
correspondent Catherine Harridge shows
us how on Twitter the president ramped
up the pressure
labeling members of the Special Counsel
team quote 13 angry Democrats who along
with Obama administration loyalists
quote will be meddling with the midterm
elections because the president said
Republicans are taking the lead as
president Trump went further questioning
why they aren't investigating Hillary
Clinton the republican-led House
Oversight and judiciary committees are
preparing for a new round of key FBI
interviews in early June witnesses
include FBI espionage Chief Bill
pre-snap
who oversaw the Clinton email and Russia
counterintelligence case while the
Russia probe officially opened in late
July 2016 Comey testified pre-stamped
told him not to inform Congress for
months she was the decision of the head
of our counterintelligence division and
just again to get the detailed on the
record why was the decision made not to
brief senior congressional leadership
because of the sensitivity of the matter
these text messages between FBI agent
Peters strong priest apps number to an
FBI lawyer lisa page are drying fresh
scrutiny because they indicate priests
tab went to london two months before the
FBI officially opened the russia case a
congressional source questioned whether
the trip was connected one committee
republican said pre-snap quote needs to
be questioned about his actions
regarding the so-called russia collusion
case including his trip to london in May
2016 and his relationship with the FBI
informant the chairman of the freedom
caucus wants more on the timing and
whether the informant and the bureau
were working together for weeks
before July 2016 when did it start
we do know that actually those
confidential human sources were engaging
prior to the official FBI investigation
so the question begs at whose direction
you know what were they collecting and
who were they were according to some
Republicans and Democrats dismissed the
allegations when they
began getting evidence that the Russians
were engaged in a broad campaign to try
and influence the 2016 election I think
it was appropriate for them to use a
confidential informant to investigate
what the Russians were up to and within
the last hour the SAN Judiciary
Committee sent out a notice confirming
the Justice Department Inspector General
is scheduled to testify a week from
today about events leading up to the
2016 election including the Clinton
email case a source close to the
discussion said it's a placeholder and
warned the timing could still slip to
the following week Brett Kevin thank you